69 mille lits supprimé en 15 ans voilà
un chiffre qui circule sur les réseaux
sociaux qui interpelle sur la casse de
l'hôpital public
cette donnée est juste mais elle mérite
quelques explications
commençons par le début 1979
la loi autorise pour la première fois le
ministre de la santé a supprimé des
services et des lits dans les hôpitaux
publics
[Musique]
les premiers grands plans de
suppressions de lits remonte aux années
90 plusieurs raisons à cela
avec le progrès de la médecine la durée
des séjours hospitaliers est plus courte
qu'avant autre raison le trou de la
sécurité sociale il faut faire des
économies
quand on sait on des services évidemment
que c'est grave parce que ça bloque
l'activité
on sait plus où mettre les malades c'est
pas normal un os vidal est parfait pour
faire mais il est fait pour soigner le
message est répétée deux manifestations
et blocages partout en france en 2002
c'est patrick peloux célèbre médecin
urgentiste qui appelaient à l'aide
et là nous sommes dans une situation qui
est absolument dantesque puisqu'il n'y a
plus de lits pour pouvoir hospitalisés
les malades venant urgence et que nous
avons connu ces jours ci même des
soirées où il n'y avait pas de lits de
réanimation le nombre de lits en france
en hospitalisation complète est passé de
460 8418 en 2003 à 399 1865 en 2010 est
donc moins 68 1553
mais il faut nuancer ces données s'il ya
moins de capacité d'accueil en
hospitalisation complète
c'est notamment parce que dans les
années 80 la france a fait le choix de
l'hospitalisation ambulatoire des
séjours de moins d'une journée
on parle alors de places en
hospitalisation partielle toujours sur
la période 2003 2010 est les places en
hospitalisation partielle sont passés de
49 1363 à 75 mille quatre cent cinquante
deux plus 20089 unis pas de quoi
compenser les quelque soixante neuf
mille places perdues en hospitalisation
complète
la difficulté se fait surtout sentir
pendant les périodes tendues lors
d'épidémies de grippe par exemple ou en
temps de canicule comme ici en 2006 pour
être encore dans le coup voir comment
les lits virtuel enfin comparons la
capacité d'accueil avec d'autres pays
touchés par le cos vide 19
d'après les dernières données de l'oscd
eu en 2017
la france comptait six lits pour 1000
habitants bien moins que la corée du sud
- que l'allemagne
mais plus que les états unis l'italie et
la chine
[Musique]